go on over to the side there for
instance place the scissors like this
a little further
this is the fourth operation this
morning for her
she specializes in female victims of
genital mutilation
they come to the sandini women's shelter
in a poor neighborhood of north paris
most of them have had their clitorises
circumcised as little
girls some experience pain during
intercourse and others complain that
they feel no pleasure
they seek help from gynecologist
they suffer both physically and
psychologically from the effects of the
traditional ritual mutilation she says
this morning a woman came to me and told
me how important this operation was for
her sense of identity
she wanted to feel physically whole
again to get back what was taken from
her
gives them back what she can
which doctor doctor
affected women from the african
community trust this doctor who
immigrated from lebanon
female circumcision is prohibited in
france even so there are unreported
cases but most of the women were
circumcised in their home countries in
africa
among them is 26 year old hebu
she fled her country djibouti because of
the suffering she endured as a small
child
they woke me up
i didn't know what was going on
they said come here
my mother held onto my hands
and another woman held my feet
this other one made several cuts
when she did i just felt pain
women in france have formed an
organization
to support some 60 000 girls who french
government figures estimate have been
affected so they won't feel left alone
with the shame and the pain
they're demanding that parents stop
sending girls born in france to the
countries of ethnic origin to be
circumcised
it's insane that after 5 000 years
they're still doing it even though
everybody knows it's pointless that no
religion demands it and it has extremely
negative consequences for their health
i agree it's surreal
the mutilation is often done with
nothing more than this
it's up to her
to repair what she can of the damage in
her operations at the shelter
i have to look for the remnant of the
clitoris where it has retracted after
the circumcision
bring it back up and suture it back in
place on the body's exterior where it
was before it was cut
medically the procedure is not that
complicated but culturally it is says
khadahatem
the women's families still regard female
circumcision as an act of moral purity
it was thanks to dr attempts courage
that she managed to create a place to
deal with an issue that to many is still
such a taboo
her energy was crucial
but i think her success is equally due
to her exceptional courage and
determination
ibu doesn't want the operation for
herself she's afraid she'll feel the
pain again
but she applied for asylum in france
also to protect her daughters
my children can't experience what i went
through
never
i know the road i've traveled and i
won't let it happen to them
because it was torture
together with our patients
hopes to bring about a change
we're fighting to stop female
circumcision because obviously
prevention is better it's good to have
the operation but better never to have
been cut at all
but many still have a long road to
travel so
plans to open more shelters like this in
france that offered the operation and a
chance at a better life for the women
who have it